da passt auch das war so hey leute was
geht ab jetzt bekommen bei neuen video
ich habe heute clement und griechische
dabei von griechisch studios und hier
deinen tvs klima davis auf jeden fall
haben wir uns gedacht ich habe das schon
vor einem halben jahr oder so habe ich
dazu zwei teile raus gehen und zwei
dinge wie sie mädchen und jungs machen
haben wir es wieder paar coole sachen
rausgesucht wir wünschen ganz viel spaß
falls euch gefällt das noch nach oben da
und viel spaß mit dem video fast so
leute ich würde sagen wir fahren einen
punkt eins und zwar haben wir uns da
überlegt diskussion also generell
einfach diese diskussion da gibt's auch
so ein unterschied vor allem dann wenn
halt einmal der junge recht hat und wenn
das mädchen recht hatte was wir damit
meinen schaut mal rein
was eltern 40h passt auch das war so ich
war mit der gabi auf der toilette ja und
dann warte ich war mit der gabel
autolenker als ram einen fehler
schädigung es war mein fehler
wieso läuft jetzt okay was laberst du
dass er gibt alles gar kein alles okay
du hast recht hey ich hab keine ahnung
ich bin dumm du hast recht du bist
allwissend weiß was ohne schildert erich
tut mir leid ich geboren bin ja ganz
ehrlich zu mir kann ja nichts für so
leute
nächster punkt ziemlich interessant
glaube ich und zwar ich weiß nicht ob
uns da alle zustimmt werden von euch
aber schluss machen ein mädchen und ein
junge viel spaß du ich muss dir was
sagen ich finde das passt einfach gar
nicht mehr zwischen sich macht schluss
zu reden sein ich habe in letzter zeit
wieder extrem viel nachgedacht und ich
bin zu dem entschluss gekommen dass ich
wirklich ein bisschen mehr zeit für mich
brauche deshalb nein es hat nichts mit
dir zu tun aber es liegt an mir selbst
und ich brauche einfach noch zeit ich
muss mich selbst ein bisschen isolieren
und gleich eine woche oder zwei es ist
natürlich nichts endgültiges aber warum
braucht einfach zeit für mich selbst
weiß ich und ich bin ich wirklich
brauche einfach nur ein bisschen
ich muss für mich alleine seien es liegt
nicht an dir aber ist das gehalt von
beacon leute letzter punkt ich hab's
schon sehr oft auch mal angesprochen
aber wir sind jetzt hat in köln also wir
können das auch gut verfilmen deswegen
gibt es hier als dritten punkt shoppen
ich denke ihr könnt euch alle ein
unterschied da vorstellen aber sie
zeigen was wir meinen was man überhaupt
das nämlich
ist das dein verdammtes ernst ist jetzt
schon die 5 zu hause statt zwei jeans
mitgebracht steht ihr eine leggins
mitgebracht und diese anderen komischen
dinger ohne scheiß wie lange brauchst du
noch und direkt heute zeigt sich doch
endlich mal leute falls ihr noch gehabt
auf einen vierten teil oder so dann gebt
doch nach oben falls euch generell
gefallen hat und weiß ja auf jeden fall
bescheid
in der video beschreibungen sind nochmal
die beiden kanäle von clement und
geschirr eingewendet es auch auf jeden
fall ab würde mich sehr freuen falls die
auch abonniert und hier auf der linken
seite geht es weiter mit meinem letzten
video das war mit meinem bruder jack
dass auf jeden fall ab und die auf der
anderen seite mit dem letzten teil hier
vor und macht so weiter
wir sehen uns am samstag wieder trennen